no
guadix y sus alrededores un pueblo que
debe casi enteramente bajo tierra en el
corazón de las montañas de arcilla con
más de 6000 cuevas habitadas es el lugar
con la mayor concentración de viviendas
en cuevas de europa carmen tiene una una
herencia de su familia toda era de mis
padres y provenía de sus antepasados de
sus abuelos bisabuelos e incluso hasta
mis tatarabuelos es decir yo tengo
documentación de que esta cuerda está
cuidada por detenerse aproximadamente
150 años esta casa ha sido renovada de
generación en generación
en cuanto haya vivían aquí ni había
electricidad ni había baño e incluso el
baño se hizo cuando ya estaba yo grande
y sus hijos está planeando sacarle
provecho
este mamá yo me quedo en la cueva yo me
quedo en el pueblo están trabajando
fuera pero ya que su intención inicial
final aquí al pueblo
la misma satisfacción para la familia
plantón yo no cambio mi cueva no la
cambio por una casa
la razón es que el calor exterior es
abrumador más de 40 grados en verano
vámonos para drenthe porque aquí en la
calle hace muchísimo calor
20 grados más fresco en el interior y
cuanto más se adentran en las montañas
mejor es el aislamiento digital a 30
metros bajo tierra aquí estáis a 40
metros bajo tierra allí hay como dos
aires acondicionados muy fresca no hace
falta el aire acondicionado en verano ni
calefacción en invierno el resultado la
factura energética es especialmente baja
una ventaja innegable según florentina
antes vivía en una casa convencional
porque yo la he cagado
pienso que la banda
ya no
otro punto positivo es que la familia
puede cavar en la arcilla lo puedes
subir más para arriba o los padres de
hamás para abajo os puede hacer un
dibujo árabe o puede hacer uno de él
el romano los arreglos son posibles pero
para ampliar es mejor recurrir a
profesionales
estos canteros especializados se llaman
picadores
ahora mismo hemos desgastado y estamos
dando en el pico fino
jose creó su empresa hace 30 años son
pequeños armarios para colgar ropa por
el jersey
no es arquitecto pero conoce todos los
trucos del oficio para evitar
desprendimientos
empezando por la forma del techo
sujeta más un arco en la arcilla de
arcilla que una viga de cemento una
construcción especialmente ecológica
no hay aditivo químico et al
segundo porque no ocupamos espacios si
no ocupamos dentro de la montaña
no estamos ocupando espacios y luego las
ventajas de que te aísla de un montón de
cosas perjudiciales para el ser humano
como por ejemplo todas las ondas que
produce la telefonía móvil o los rayos
que evitan que emite el sol
este modelo de casa fue diseñado mucho
antes de la llegada de los teléfonos
móviles fue desarrollado por mercenarios
magrebíes en el siglo 11
ellos
exportan su tradición constructiva a la
península ibérica y digamos que es el
germen para la posterior construcción
de las cuevas en la comarca siendo ésta
la mayor concentración de huevos
habitados del mundo en un principio
estos musulmanes vinieron a apoyar al
califato pero más tarde se rebelaron y
se refugiaron en estas cuevas con forma
de fortaleza
pero una piedra que ellos podían girar
para tapar la entrada
hasta hoy este lugar de vida estaba
estigmatizan los grupos de población más
desfavorecidos los que la han utilizado
precisamente por esa por esas
condiciones de arquitectura barata pero
que hoy en día pues cuando están
conociendo un
repunte y esta agencia inmobiliaria se
da cuenta de ello
por qué
ante este aumento de la demanda el
incremento de los precios es exponencial
que estaba de 85 mil euros y hace 50
años pues podría valer al cambio pues
mil mil quinientos euros hoy en día en
un negocio interesante como inversión
también es interesante porque en la
cueva que se venden y que se vuelven a
revender siempre tienen un beneficio los
profesionales del turismo también se
benefician del fenómeno los turistas
extranjeros como esta pareja se
sorprenden al descubrir estos increíbles
o tenga como corre de miel amarilla
entonces está muy bien
y hay que arropar ya que si a lo largo
de los últimos 20 años este gestor
hotelero ha seguido expandiéndose el
número de casas trogloditas aumentó de 6
a 19 la popularidad del lugar sigue
creciendo desde el año pasado incluso
forma parte de una zona protegida por la
unesco del geoparque de granada